in the game of golf every hole begins
with the tee shot and over the years
players have been finding ways to drive
the ball farther and farther and farther
in 1980 the hardest hitter on Tour
average 274 yards from the tee but these
days the best players average closer to
320 yards with individual drives
sometimes clearing over 400 yards but
could those numbers go up today we're
gonna look at why driving a golf ball
450 yards is almost impossible to find
out what it takes I got a lesson from
one of the PGA's hardest hitters out
local butter there use motion capture
technology to compare my swing to the
pros and looked at how changes to
equipment have helped golfers drive even
farther we add additional layers to add
speed now before we dig into this
question let's clarify what we mean by
longest dry because in golf there are a
couple different ways to measure a drive
one is called total distance and the
other is called carry distance
Dustin Johnson is one of the top drivers
in the PGA his longest drive ever
recorded 489 yards but that is using the
total distance metric which measures how
far the ball flies through the air and
bounces and rolls before coming to a
stop
here's the thing total yards doesn't
always reflect a player's true range if
you're playing on a sloped course you
ball can roll a lot and if you get a
lucky bounce off a hard surface it can
add a ton of yards to your total drive
distance in 1992 Carl Cooper's tee shot
from the 3rd hole of the Texas open
ricocheted off a golf cart path and
wound up traveling 787 yards before
rolling to a stop that's almost half a
mile the point is if you want to examine
the limits of human performance from the
tee the purist metric is arguably carry
distance not total distance
so what's carry distance it's how far
the ball travels through the air before
making first contact with the ground so
you get no bounce and no roll I can
carry it you know up to about 3:30 in
the air because we play all different
courses
you know firm soft whatever style of
course like so
always just look at carry numbers
because then you can always figure out
how far it's gonna roll out because
carry is gonna be affected by things
like wind it's gonna be affected by the
humidity would altitude your app but the
total distance that's like what kind of
course you're on right what kind of
grass is like what kind of elevation
you're at or what kind of slope there is
on the course it's a lot less relevant
to your play exactly so we're gonna
focus on carry distances right about now
some of you might be wondering about
long drive competitions where players
compete to crush the ball as far as they
possibly can and we'll come back to
those I promise they're actually where
we got our four hundred fifty yard limit
but to understand long drive
competitions you first need to
appreciate how drives work on the PGA so
I met up with Dustin Johnson at his home
course in Central Florida to learn the
basics I am going to go try driving and
I would love if you have a time to just
watch me for a little bit sure give me a
couple tips I'll even tee it up for you
for the first time then you're gonna
have to do it after that now I hadn't
swung a club in almost 20 years but I
figured I'd at least be able to hit the
ball just contact us all you're trying
to make like I said contact things were
really out of whack my grip wasn't right
my stance was off but with a little
practice and lots of patience from
Johnson hey I eventually made some
property we recorded our shots using a
radar system called track man which
captures things like distance spin rate
and where the balls land most of my
drives were well under 200 yards while
most of Johnson's traveled closer to 300
and unlike me he wasn't swinging as hard
as he could
the fact is distance doesn't matter that
much if your shots are landing all over
the place like mine were DJ's drives
have a lot of power but they're also
precise and accurate but being able to
hit the ball really far is obviously
still crucial so in terms of fitness and
strength what is the most important
piece of the puzzle in terms of
maximizing your Drive distance the most
important piece probably the legs you
know you create a lot of power from
from your lower body and your legs and
then you know obviously flexibility in
the upper body
but you know and strength I mean you
kind of using your whole body so it's
all very important and then there's
technique there are several parts of the
swing to consider there's a starting
position the backswing top of the
backswing when the club briefly pauses
the downswing impact and then the
follow-through the pros are very
consistent highly consistent that's
Stanford's Jessica Rose who co-authored
a study comparing the swings of
professional golfers to amateurs it is
that smooth fluid movement with no
hesitation that creates that power
generation Rose says that driving is
essentially a sequence of rotations with
energy and momentum being passed from
the legs hips and lower back to the
shoulders arms and wrists each of those
rotations works like a link in a chain
if one of those links breaks the drive
suffers to emphasize just how different
the pros are from amateurs they ran my
swing through a motion-capture analysis
and compared it to their database of
professional golfers now perhaps the
biggest difference in your swing
compared to the pros there's the back
swing it's muted your s factor so your
tilt of your shoulders are much less
than the pros look how much less my
shoulders tilt than Johnson's it's a
major break in my kinetic chain causing
me to sacrifice distance on my drives
that's the thing peak rotational
velocities are important but maybe even
more important is linking each of those
rotations together once you've mastered
that fluid movement TaylorMade golf's
Brian basil says that the ingredients
for a long drive are actually pretty
easy to define so for a long drive you
really need four things you need to
optimize four things you need head speed
so that's really comes down to the
player how fast you can swing we can
change it through club length and the
weight of the club ball speed
so how solid do you hit it and how
efficient and how how good is that
driver so you get the most out of it
third launch you need to launch it high
but you have to have the right spin rate
to go with it so 17 degrees
and say 1500 rpms of spin high launch
low spin would maximize carry and roll
may not be the most playable launch
condition but it certainly would get to
distance but when it comes to golf a
player's game also has a lot to do with
their equipment in fact it can have such
a big effect on performance but the
United States Golf Association has rules
about the size shape and weight of
players clubs the size of the head 460
cubic centimetres is ultimately the
larger size and all the drivers today
for the most part are there the length
of the golf club 48 inches is is that is
the rule albeit most players are less
than that 45 and a half inches is
typical the USGA z' rules are meant to
standardize the game but they also limit
players power one of the most important
restrictions has to do with something
called coefficient of restitution or cor
in essence this tells you how much
energy is transferred in a collision
between two objects like a club and a
ball if you swing two otherwise
identical clubs at the exact same speed
the one with the higher cor will hit the
ball farther so we're looking at the
inside of an m6 driver head you'll see
the the carbon fiber the titanium even
the slots down in the bottom here this
is all to maximize the use of weight and
the flexibility the back of the face
inverted cone technology that spreads
the cor cor is described as a number
between 0 & 1 current regulations don't
allow for a club head to exceed point 8
3 cor but with modern materials and
design methods equipment manufacturers
can actually exceed that number so we'll
make this face over the COR limit to
begin with and then we'll measure each
head will inject a certain amount of
resin to bring that head back to the
legal limit we'll measure it again we'll
feed that back through the system and we
can do need to do that every single head
that we make and then there's the ball
itself there's a lot of engineering and
science that goes into the design of a
golf ball to make it perform the way it
does how important is the ball in the
player club ball equation in terms of
distance it's played a critical
in driver distance over the last 20
years when wound golf balls were the
most popular on tour those golf balls
generated a lot of backspin so what's
happened with solid constructions or
multi-layer constructions is the golf
ball spins less off the driver which
over the years has given the player the
ability to further increase launch angle
launch angle coupled with lower spin is
going to give players more distance a
lot of people associate a golf ball as
being this really hard object but it's
actually quite elastic right and it's
it's a function of how hard it's being
hit that you see that elasticity sort of
come to life that's right I would I
would consider the golf ball spring
there's not only the golf ball that's
compressing and that face is another
type of spring so it's the combination
of the two that give you the ultimate
ball speed so there's the driver design
and maximizing the how that golf ball
comes off the face with the driver
design and then there's the golf ball
design trying to maximise velocity with
just within the golf ball itself some of
the earliest golf balls were filled with
feathers and over the years
manufacturers have tried all kinds of
things to improve their performance as
recently as 20 years ago some balls have
liquid inside of it you asked most
people you cut a golf ball in half what
would you see inside I don't think most
people would have any idea yeah this has
so this has a urethane cover and then it
has windings that were over there to
help increase velocity and help generate
spin and this one this particular ball
has a solid Center there are other golf
balls like this one that's filled with
corn syrup that is corn syrup uh-huh
that oh and look at that so as we he
says the corn syrup was supposed to help
reduce spin they also wrap the ball
scores in rubber bands which offered
players control but at the expense of
reaction but starting around the turn of
the millennium players began to favor
balls made from concentric layers of
rubber and plastic that allowed them to
hit the ball far in some circumstances
and with control in others and this is
what those look like on the inside
the modern golf ball is going to be
composed of rubber inner core poly
butadiene and you can change the the
compression of that core depending on
what type
performance you want and then the golf
ball it's gonna have multiple layers
depending on what you're trying to
achieve and what type of player you're
targeting on our TP v and TP v X we use
a five-letter construction which starts
with that soft poly butadiene core and
then we add multiple layers three
additional layers that are gonna add
speed the last layer is that familiar
outer shell talk to me about the
importance of that dimple pattern the
dimples in general they create less drag
when you think about a golf ball it's a
sphere and ultimately it's really not
the most aerodynamic body it's it
creates a wake when it's going through
when it's punching through the air and
what the dimples do is they reduce the
drag by about half the USGA has size and
weight restrictions designed to limit a
balls performance - it has to be at
least one point six eight inches in
diameter and weigh no more than one
point six 2 ounces they also test balls
to see how far they travel under very
specific launch conditions when struck
by a standardized Club at a standardized
speed no ball may travel more than 320
yards if it does players can't use it
naturally some players hit harder than
average which is why they can drive
farther than 320 yards sometimes a lot
farther and that brings us back to long
drive it's well exactly what it sounds
like sport in which players compete to
drive a golf ball as far as they
possibly can in April long driver Tim
Burke won a competition with a monstrous
474 yard drive but that was his drives
total distance so what was his carry
watch again it's right around 450 yards
here's the thing long drive competitions
used to allow equipment that violated
USGA rules and that made it tough to
compare to the PGA but these days the
clubs and balls that long drivers use
all technically conform to the USGA
specifications but they're right at the
limit take club length for example most
players on the PGA used clubs between 44
and 45 inches but long drivers
for the maximum allowed 48 inches they
also rely on more aggressive mechanics
club faces with less loft and more
compressed balls all of which combine
for you guessed it longer drive
distances so don't expect to see
anything like that on the PGA Tour
anytime soon why not in the PGA remember
the ultimate objective is to get to the
hole so accuracy and precision are
really important
there is almost no incentive to ever
completely sacrifice control entirely in
the name of distance based on everything
that I've studied the golfer would still
have to make a significant improvement
again in their fitness to be able to
swing harder at it here I mean we see
long drive guys do it you know it's
definitely possible
you just have to swing incredibly hard
and you have to have all the right
things line up maybe one day the USGA
rules will allow players to use clubs
with more efficient energy transfer or
father flying balls or maybe we'll see
larger courses that encourage players to
hit even longer drives but until that
happens remember that what professional
golfers are doing is already almost
impossible
[Music]